vintage car meets bring antique and
classy cars and their owners together
the models are as widely varied as the
people who drive them
[Music]
this year more than 100 antique cars pre
and post war models have come together
on our stats market square that mixed in
with the antique cars is a BMW 320i that
looks like a modern convertible but it's
a modern classic a collector's item that
has to be at least fifteen years old to
count as an antique in Germany a car has
to be 30 years old
[Music]
the BMW's owner andreas clay building
explains that it's a 1992 model so it's
no antique but at 25 years old it counts
as a modern classic on Babli BMW boasts
a 129 horsepower engine a sport
suspension and sport exhaust and Lea
says it has the M sports package so it
rides a bit lower
it's a four-seat convertible with six
cylinders to him
that's what BMW stands for six cylinders
purring Andreas is a member of an
antique car club and he's already
looking forward to mounting the special
license plate on his Beemer in five
years but when he bought it he wasn't
even looking for an antique car this
explains that all he wanted was a car
that would get him to work he likes
driving with the top down he only
gradually became interested in the
Beemer as a classic he began reading
vintage car magazines and realized his
model was starting to come to the
attention of classic car buffs the
series was launched in 1985 so the very
first of them already have the antique
car plates but his BMW is from 1992 so
he'll have to wait a few more years to
keep it in good condition he doesn't
take it out as often as he used to and
gives it more tender loving care
[Music]
and Aleya still loves to drive with the
top down especially after dark
through the eiffel hill country or to
get some ice cream and come back but it
takes more than TLC to make an antique
car this is a vintage car meet and they
have to be at least 30 years old do
Andres and his car get funny looks at
events like this
[Music]
Hammond yosef Moya believes a club like
this lives from variety and this
beautiful Beamer is a part of it just
like this nice Morris they represent the
two extremes of the time span covered by
the cars here as it happens on delious
isn't the only modern classic owner in
the line aft antique car club this
Porsche Targa is a few years older than
his Beemer but it isn't old enough yet
for these special plates either
[Music]
mark Stephanie this points out that no
car is antique right away it only
becomes an antique over the years his
will be 30 years old next month and he
thinks it's great that some people are
here with nice newer ones as well not
even the exhibitors of rare vintage
classics turn up their noses at the BMW
320i they're only too glad to welcome
the newer cars into they're not so
exclusive club
[Music]
Billy blues thinks the antique car
events should accept the modern classics
because this is their future it wouldn't
do to tell their owners to come back
when their cars reach age 30 they might
not come back at all and not everyone
has the money to buy a true antique car
to go over their normal Altima aundrea
since 1992 BMW also has its fans at the
antique car meet on delious we'll take
good care of his car so he'll have his
classic modern or not for many years to
come andhe biases BMW 320i has made the
transition from just an old used car to
a modern classic even as two sons now
think it's cool and argue over who will
get it later on but that's many years
down the road and by the time it's
passed on to the next generation it'll
be a genuine antique
you